Republicans take control of the House
NBC News projects so it is now formally
confirmed we we knew this was going to
happen that's why we're all saying hey
we get it Republicans won the house but
now it's formalized there's no recounts
Nothing's Gonna Change the only question
now is how many seats will the
Republicans actually gain in the end of
this it's looking like 219 but it could
actually be a little bit more depending
on recounts and we'll see but uh I just
want to point out this is massive
they're already talking about
investigating fauci
and we and the lead for the show is like
Paul Pelosi has weird you know lovers
trist romp Hammer attack or something
like that
because I kind of well I guess I guess
we kind of knew the Republicans were
gonna take that but the question that I
guess for everybody else is
how excited are you on a scale of uh one
to ten I am three only because I when I
think of this issues and what we're
going through right now we've talked a
lot about left and right and blue and
red but I'm starting to think it's
actually like um an economic plan that's
happening right now it's it's very
um complicated there's lots of people
with lots of different ideologies making
moves and trying to take control and
they want us to think that it's a binary
thing between them and us but really
it's a bunch of different economic
pressures so this stuff is kind of like
the mask that we are talking about that
was is being created in my opinion by
the villain if it's a villain you know
if there's going to be a villain maybe
I'm the villain one to ten how how much
I'm excited for the Republicans is that
what you're asking for them for them
gaining control of the house zero I
don't think it's gonna matter I didn't
say zero to ten I said one through ten
Luke come on
I
in a house yes they have subpoena power
and investigatory power I'd be very
surprised if they do I have already
started talking about doing come on you
got Thomas Massey in the house
he'll do something Rand Paul's
apparently having meetings as well he's
in the Senate I know he doesn't have the
same power but it's not looking too good
what do you think they did they did
choose McCarthy and and McConnell for a
leadership exactly so I I Echo Luke
sentiment I would go with the one I want
I just don't think it just does I don't
think that
they I hate saying they I just don't
think that they will let us win
I think it's it leans towards like the Q
and on stuff like where you go all right
we got the house now we got all our
people in here we go we're gonna
investigate fauci's going down we're
going after this guy we're coming out
with our hammers uh touche touche you
know and and and and once again it's
setting us up for for this
disappointment when we need to be saying
looking at the reality of it
unless well I I look I am I'm certainly
not a one I'm not gonna pretend like
Republicans coming in uh pushing
McCarthy and McConnell to the top again
is any kind of real Victory but 31
members of the House did reject McCarthy
so there may be some leverage from the
free I think it was mostly the freedom
caucus they were basically like nope
yeah I think we'll see some stuff look
we're not gonna We're Not Gonna uh win
everything instantly but I'm feeling
pretty good I mean it's look it's better
than Democrats doing January six
hearings I agree and and I think and I'm
not completely sure on the process but
uh the the vote for leadership doesn't
take place until January I think until
they reconvene and well they did you
mean for the party for the house they
yeah they I think oh oh it's right it's
nomination I think is that what happened
I think so no no no no no I think I
think I think McConnell is he did win
didn't he
I don't know someone factual I'm pretty
sure they they've they've already had
the vote Matt Gates I think maybe not
Matt Gates
um and someone and I can't remember who
in the Senate were trying to get a
postponed saying like I think it might
have been Holly I'm not sure yeah saying
like we should wait on this but I'm
pretty sure they did maybe I'm thinking
of the house it says Mitch McConnell
wins secret ballot election a continued
leading Senate Republicans seven hours
ago yeah yeah
I know that's just my wishful thinking
I've got like this feeling like if we're
talking about the future of humanity
that it's a big Global project and we as
Americans a lot of us are stuck in the
American perspective where we're only
looking at ourselves and that if we can
do this then the whole world will win
but like I think there are a lot of
people in the rest of the world are
looking at us like goofballs obsessed
with the circus that we're in right now
and like hey you know let's let's exit
the circus and look around
sort of so so one to ten what are you
Tim
McCarthy well so from MacArthur I mean
this is essentially what you tried to
get me down no no no that's why I said
zero I'm excited that there's a small
handful of Republicans who can have some
pressure ability but uh I'll put it this
way if if one is I'm extremely
disappointed ten as I'm excited as I
ever have been and five is kind of yeah
I'll say six
you know like when you say one you're
saying like I'm mad about this this is
the worst thing ever this is bad for us
five is where you're like meh I say six
I'm cautiously optimistic that the the
circumstances we have to look forward to
with Democrats is more January 6
nonsense waste of our time things that
no one cares about with Republicans it's
like okay I guess hopefully they'll
start talking about fauci or some maybe
not but whatever the January 6th stuff
is done yeah it's subjective because I
just don't see any kind of larger
Solutions out there I don't see them
making life better for the average
American especially with McCarthy uh
just controlling everything he's going
to be protecting a lot of people inside
of the establishment and making sure
that the Republicans aren't too wild
aren't too crazy don't make too much uh
crazy uh moves so so he's there to keep
everyone in line and I think that's
exactly what they're going to be doing
here and it's not like they have a lot
of wiggle room here they barely were
able to win this so as far as my
optimism and politics it's none my
optimism is with the people of the
United States it's with local officials
local individuals taking charge of their
life and being responsible for
themselves rather than giving all of
their power and authority and money to
politicians that don't give a damn about
it okay okay no I agree on a lot of
those points we have this other story
from timcast.com that goes along with
this house Democrats maneuver to stop
Trump's 2024 presidential bid house rep
cites the 14th amendment's Insurrection
Clause as basis to deny return to high
office
this is what we have to look forward to
if the Democrats were trained retained
control of the house that's a good point
they'd be just going the 14th Amendment
man they'd be banging on the walls we we
ought to pad the walls to help them out
because you think they can't get a
republican to flip in the house I think
they can I think they still could go
forward with this and then they just go
to the Republican and be like you know
that trip you made to that Island you
know those videotapes we have on here
are you going to vote with us or do you
do you want some larger expose on TMZ
what do you want there or they'll go to
McCarthy be like look McCarthy we'll
we'll give you you know something we'll
give you a little bit but we want to
make sure this happens McCarthy would be
for this we got to understand this yeah
Old Republic at that point would be for
this so this is why again I don't have a
lot of Hope right and meanwhile they
have the media in their pocket and so as
they're doing that they're churning out
the narrative and they're just once
again corralling the truth which puts us
in a very difficult position when we
have things like nuclear war what's
happening with in the medical side of
things what's happening to to to all of
us our country is being destroyed
by the Democrats and Republicans by both
sides by both parties it's a new opoly
it's a two-party system that that
pretends to be fighting each other most
of the time sometimes they really do
fight but most of the times it's all
pretend it's all WWE it's all
entertainment it's all Showmanship but
that feels a little archaic to me I mean
I I agree mostly but since Donald Trump
got into office we started seeing a
whole bunch of libertarian and America
First candidates I'm not saying they
overlap they're they're both
anti-establishment factions the house
Freedom caucus where Ron DeSantis I
believe he helped found it has been
pushing back and expanding within their
within the Republican party so that's
what I'm looking at obviously I'm not
excited for Mitch McConnell no one likes
this guy this is the funny thing I
pulled up the Civics polls and went
through every single demographic not a
single demographic views him favorably
not even Republicans
how's this guy leading the charge
because there's because there's they're
all cowards exactly there's a reason FTX
was donating not only overwhelmingly to
Democrats but also to the GOP people
don't forget a lot of when it comes to
this larger FTX story which is I think
very important you don't just see the
the Democrats being bought off here you
see about 23 million dollars going
specifically to the Republicans as well
so a big money plays a lot of influence
in our politics and we have to
understand once we get rid of that
influence once we get rid of that money
then we could actually have some real
conversations but at the end of the day
these Representatives aren't
representing us they're representing a
special interest that bought them off
paid them off and they're going to be
doing their bidding no matter what and
there is some infighting sure but but
even before that there was the Tea Party
there was Essence of people saying this
is crazy that we're dealing with these
two parties here that are controlling
our dialogue that are controlling our
life we need to stop this because this
is how they fool and kid everyone to
vote for the lesser of two evils while
always presenting evil and I'm just sick
of it I'm not going to sit here and
defend the GOP leadership or their party
or anything like that I'm only excited
for the small faction of like the
freedom caucus and the people who are
actually pushing back obviously
the fact that they've chosen McCarthy
and McConnell for leadership it shows
you exactly where this Congress is going
to be
and it's unfortunate that's reality
you're going to get a whole bunch of
Republicans saying like no now now we
can't go off investigating Joe Biden
because we're going to take the high
road and just let them do whatever they
want or it's going to be more like we we
got to take the high road on this and
not investigate have it help me if they
find out how I was involved
yeah they're they're definitely are a
lot of of good people that are making
inroads that have been elected that that
are
uh making decisions based on the the
right things and not that videotape
coming out of that trip you made last
week or how much money they're gonna get
or
um things like that they're working for
their you know the treasure here on
Earth you think there are people that
are have actually good intentions and
are bought off I think so sure somebody
like Marjorie Taylor green I think you
know Thomas Massey yeah sure I mean I
think too they came Marjorie already had
a successful business when she ran I
think Thomas also I don't think Thomas
Massey is rich okay I don't know what
his system yeah he's a MIT he built the
the cluck capacitor yeah an inventor my
friend has one of those in New Hampshire
Jane you and he's an awesome human being
he built he builds cluck capacitors
they're incredible it's I I said this
before on the show I talked to Thomas
Massey after he was on the show last
time he was like dude Congress is it's
like a I don't know how he exactly
described it he's like it's like a
fraternity it's like a not a fraternity
but like it's like high school like
people emotionally yelling and like I'm
not gonna talk to that [ __ ] you know
like that kind of stuff and he's like an
engineer scientist and is like we this
is insane we need more science we need
more engineering yeah and he's just like
wow but you know you do it anyway
because you know you're called to it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time